social media has played a big role
during this pandemic and as we all know
it can sometimes be misleading 8 news
now reporter victoria saha spoke to a
social media expert today to give us
some tips on how we can know what's real
and what's not victoria
it's 2021 and most of us now have one of
these right whether it's to make calls
or text or scroll through social media
to get our latest scoop from around the
world but information that you see might
not always be true we are now more than
a year and half into the pandemic and
social media is filled with both facts
and rumors rumors such as the virus as a
hoax to there's a microchip in the
vaccine to most recently people thinking
that a horse dewormer will cure you of
cobit we recently reported people in
nevada have been poisoned by it and it
all starts with a simple rumor going
viral making many believe it
communications professor emma francis
bloomfield of unlv says this is where it
becomes dangerous
this idea that horse dewormer reduces
inflammation right if that's true and
why people use it on their horses people
then extrapolate that into oh it will be
useful for humans as well that's where
the problem is right there's like a sort
of a kernel or a nugget of truth but the
way people are applying it and spinning
it off is what makes it really dangerous
she says the big problem is that social
media platforms are used by both
credible and non-credible sources which
can be confusing catchy headlines can
grab your attention quick but you should
always verify it
now social media hasn't been all that
negative during the pandemic when most
of you got vaccinated you posted on
social media that you got vaccinated or
you posted your vaccine card professor
bloomfield says this is a way to spread
positive messages reporting live from
the newsroom victoria saha 8 news now